the business community has a strong
reaction to the president's withdrawal
from the Paris agreement many prominent
companies including IBM Exxon Mobil and
Amazon support the Accord both Tesla CEO
Elon Musk and Disney's Bob Iger say they
will leave the president's Business
Advisory Council because of the
president's move
General Electric CEO Jeff Immelt
expressed his disappointment he tweeted
quote climate change is real industry
must now lead and not depend on
government CBS News financial
contributor Mellody Hobson is in
Washington
melody good morning I know you've been
talking to a lot of CEOs a lot of
business leaders what effect you think
this will have on our economy that is
unclear I've had the opportunity to
interface probably with somewhere in the
neighborhood of two dozen business
leaders from around the world very very
high-level executives and they expressed
a lot of dismay some discussed some
disdain this made some anger but overall
they were unclear about the effect on
the economy because you had two
countervailing forces of new jobs being
created in new energy new energy areas
as well as this waning of some of the
old sectors melody the headline in one
German newspaper said America first
earth last number-one what do you think
the message at what message do you think
it sends to the world and have you heard
about any upside here so the message to
the world is not good I've asked
specifically CEOs from India to Europe
to China what they thought as well as
the American CEOs and they said this is
bad for the American brand one foreign
leader said to me who was on the board
of a big auto company he said listen it
calls into question your ability to
renegotiate anything and it especially
calls into question our president's
message last week in NATO about honoring
our commitments to NATO so this is not a
good thing the people that I talk to the
business leaders I talked to a word
about America's influence in major trade
organizations and major international
institutions around the world where we
have had a leading role and an
influential role will that be diminished
to the detriment of America absolutely
so again another CEO said to me we're
just ceding leadership to China
it's hard to imagine that we're just
letting them take the mantle right from
us to pick it up and lead on things like
climate change which were our issues the
treaty that and that the dot the the
issue that we brought to the world stage
so this is not a good thing what about
the argument that this will keep coal
jobs here in the US this is really a
challenging argument these this
conversation around coal is really
perfect split flexing so I checked with
the Bureau of Labor Statistics as of
February there were 50,000 coal jobs in
America but if you looked at just jobs
related to wind energy alone there were
80,000 and that number is growing coal
peaked years ago and because of Cheaper
national natural gas as well as other
resources this is not me in any way not
being concerned about coal miners and
their their future but to hang on to
that as a narrative is just wrong Melda
Hobson thank you so much thank you